thank you to short form for sponsoring
this video to get a free trial and an
additional 25 discount on the annual
subscription which includes unlimited
access to their browser extension join
short form at shortform.com
microcosmos or click the link in the
description
[Music]
I'm going to cut right to the chase
we're looking at the inside of a potato
right now yes seriously when you take a
little slide of that bland mushy flesh
and put it under the microscope with
polarized light this is what you see I
can't speak for you but this is not what
I expected potatoes are a great food but
they're not exactly the most exciting to
look at I certainly never expected to
see something that could double as the
stained glass windows in a Sailor Moon
fever dream but that varied array of
colors is built out of something simple
starch granules those granules act as
storage for the plant's carbohydrate
Supply which is then stashed in the
potato tubers underground the starches
are meant to provide energy for the
potato plant but of course plenty of
animals including us like to make use of
the potato sparkly starches as well and
when you look inside other foods like
passion fruit and bananas you can see
those starches as well sometimes packed
into cells or at other times flowing
across the slide perhaps if you've been
journeying with us through the
microcosmos for a while now you may have
noticed that these images look very
different from our usual sites of course
that's partially because we're looking
at very different things from our
typical fare usually we're looking into
pond water or whatever other fascinating
bit of nature that James our master of
microscopes usually looks at but right
now our sights are coming to us directly
from the kitchen but also things are
looking a bit different because today
we're looking through the lens of a
different master of microscopes her name
is Chloe Savar and you can follow her on
Instagram at tartababe
Chloe got her start in microscopy three
years ago after seeing some videos on
Instagram that piqued her interest she
started slowly at first but it's since
built into a huge passion helping her
see the world through that combination
of artistry and science that microscopy
inherently Blends together
these videos of the crystals inside of
dragon fruits are some of our favorites
of hers it looks like she accidentally
dropped a giant container of neon
confetti onto her microscope but those
funky shapes are probably a type of
sugar called myoinositol which
crystallized as water slowly evaporated
from the slide if you watch more of what
Chloe sees through her microscope you'll
see spectacular colors over and over
again as she renders different crystals
in Vivid terms and she's able to do this
using a type of light called polarized
light which restricts the electrical
field vibrations of the light to one
plane to our eyes polarized light looks
the same as non-polarized light but
under a microscope we can see the effect
of polarized light hitting certain types
of materials in this case the crystals
in our food as it forms a dazzling
Tableau this effect has been part of the
excitement of microscopy for Chloe
especially because she loves the
saturated colors she's learning to bring
out with her microscope
that's how she's able to see the stone
cells inside of fruits like pears and
blueberries these cells aren't alive but
they still serve a purpose to support
the fruit and sometimes even to protect
them from threats like weevils their
walls are full of sturdy lignin which is
responsible for the gritty texture you
feel when you bite into a pair
even though these aren't like the
microbial life we usually watch under
the microscope there is a similar
feeling to them like we're unlocking
this tiny world that's responsible for
everything we experience it's just that
instead of say a tiny algae responsible
for the air we breathe or a parasite
that can eat away at a body we're
experiencing an invisible Universe
responsible for the way that our Foods
feel and taste and sustain us like have
you ever eaten a pineapple and
immediately scrunched your face up in
pain well that might be due to these
structures called rafides made from
calcium oxalate crystals a number of
other fruits in plants have refides and
there are a few theories about what
those rafides actually do given that
they look a lot like needles one idea is
that they might function as protection
prickling away at the mouth of anyone
who dares eat the plant but crystals
aren't the only surreal site buried in
the microscopic worlds of fruits and
vegetables if you look at the inside of
an onion or a pumpkin you can see a
streaming motion within the cells called
cytoplasmic streaming or psychosis
though we have the movement sped up a
bit here this motion is a cell at work
using a network of actin and myosin to
carry organelles and other molecules
around so they can carry out various
tasks in distant regions
we've been looking at a lot of fruits
and vegetables but that's not all Chloe
looks at if you go to her Instagram
you'll see videos of some of our
favorite microcosmos friends like
tardigrades and diatoms and worms like
James she has an office full of stinky
jars that are full of samples taken from
ponds but there has been one major
challenge to her love of searching for
microscopic life in ponds
winter in Montreal the cold temperatures
often keep her from finding new samples
for months that's why Chloe started
looking at fruits and vegetables it was
meant to help her buy the time but after
she looked at the inside of a potato she
was hooked she'd never expected starch
to be so beautiful or to find similar
structures in different types of
molecules but there they were an array
of striking colors apparent under the
microscope compared to Pond samples
which can rely on hours and hours of
patience to sort through fruits and
vegetables offered something immediate
which meant she could experiment with
the artistic side of microscopy in a
different way as well learning to bring
out those structures and colors
there is both an art and a science to
turning the fruit bowl into a subject in
this way crafting is still life that
reveals itself to not be so still after
all with every beam of light Chloe takes
us on a tour of something we see every
day and helps us see it through her eyes
something surreal and beautiful and
mind-blowing that is just within our
reach
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and thank you to short form for
sponsoring this video If you 've been
overwhelmed by the never-ending sea of
new books don't worry you're not alone
with tens of thousands of new books
hitting the shelves every week it's
impossible to read them all but fear not
short form is here to save the day with
their Incredible Book guides that offer
comprehensive summaries commentary and
Analysis and deliver key insights in
just minutes how many times have you
heard someone suggest that you read Dale
Carnegie's book How to Win Friends and
Influence People heck maybe you even
have a copy collecting dust on your
bookshelf right now that you just
haven't made time for well thankfully
for you short form can get you up to
speed with their How to Win Friends and
Influence People book guide that
contains a one-page summary a full
chapter by chapter guide and even
interactive exercises that prompt you to
reflect on the ideas you've learned and
short form knows you're always on the
Move that's why their book guides come
with audio versions allowing you to
listen and learn anytime anywhere short
form drops new book guides and articles
every week and as a subscriber you have
the power to shape their content by
voting on the books you want them to
cover next and their latest Innovation
is the short form AI browser extension
now you can experience instant summaries
wherever your web browsing takes you
blogs articles emails YouTube videos you
name it their AI extension generates
concise summaries effortlessly
delivering key ideas right to your
fingertips to get a free trial and an
additional 25 discount on the annual
subscription which includes unlimited
access to the extension join short forms
through shortform.com
microcosmos or click the link in the
description
we also want to say thank you to all of
those people whose names you're seeing
on the screen right now those are some
of our patreon patrons and we couldn't
continue to make this show without them
if you'd like to see more from Journey
to the microcosmos there should be a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign